a powerful
instinct when we meet someone we're
attracted to is to try
to please them and we can naturally
assume
that the best way we might do this is to
signal just how much we agree with their
views and choices
on pretty much all matters great and
small
so on an early dinner date when they
happen to mention that they love dancing
we'll reveal that of course we love
dancing too or when they explain how
boring they find museums
we'll hide that on a trip to berlin last
year we spent a whole fascinating day in
the galleries of the altus museum
we may not state direct falsehoods but
we stretch and bend the truth to its
limits
so as to create an impression of near
total
alignment along the way it rarely occurs
to us
that they might be performing some of
the same rigmarole for
us that they might also be adjusting
their self-presentation
in subtle but powerful ways to fit in
with what they take to be
our preferences and values there is a
tragic comic aspect
to our deepening mutual attraction two
decent people
are trying to be as nice as they can no
one is setting out to deceive
and yet gradually a set of hugely
misleading
and pretty dangerous ideas about who
each person
really is are getting established
the apparent success of our will to
please can inspire us to move in
together
and later to marry but then inevitably
the prolonged
intimate scrutiny that coupled and
brings will reveal the scale of our
mistaken expectations
in a sequence of disillusioning stages
we are each
saddened disappointed and shocked to
discover who we've ended up with
there will be recriminations rows and
fragile reconciliations
until finally one or other of us comes
to the grim
but still surprising conclusion that we
were never
really compatible or maybe we'll stick
at it with growing misery
we'll face a lifetime of holidays that
never involve the museum visits we crave
we'll have to resign ourselves to never
having the kind of sex we want
or even more grievously will eventually
embark on a furtive life
we'll seek out the moments when they're
away to pursue needs
that we've pretended not to have until
one day our double life is exposed and
we drown in bitterness
fury and sorrow yet the origin of such
nightmares
is only ever a hugely touching but
painfully
flawed and risky devotion to being an
easy match
we want to be simple and yet we end up
in a
very complicated mess a genuinely
simpler approach
would involve daring to be a bit more
complicated
from the start there is no need to be
brazen or demanding
just as there's no requirement that our
date agree or even stick around beyond
dessert
or the main course some will run away
and should
it will save everyone a lot of time in
order to be honest in seduction
we need a basic sense of acceptability
we must know that we're not perfect
but that we are not for that matter
wholly abject or shameful
our inner conviction that our oddities
are essentially reasonable
allows us to present ourselves to
another person without fear or
defensiveness
our honesty then arms us with the right
to ask our date to reveal
with similar candor what may be
individual and difficult about
their characters if they insist that
they're really
very simple and easy we're allowed to be
gently but
firmly skeptical after all they are a
human being
and to be human is to be complicated it
cannot possibly be true
that they exist without significant
quirks
being straightforward on early dates is
in the end a mechanism for two people
to fast forward time and to spare
themselves
agony we should know that a polished
surface
can't be a true picture of who anyone
can be
only once our mutual complexities have
been outlined
should we sense that we are safe in the
presence of a fellow
mature and pleasingly direct individual
we will have the simpler relationships
we desire when we can dare to share
and accommodate the actual complexities
of human nature
connect is a card game to foster
connection and closeness
with 100 questions that help couples to
rekindle affection
you